buenas tardes mi nombre es ernesto
camacho y yo soy egresado de cetys
soy hijo de un ingeniero y un artista
eso es lo que me creó a mí lo que dio mi
identidad y les voy hablar de estas dos
facetas que se conjuntaron para para que
sea lo que yo soy para darme lo que lo
que soy hoy
en la parte del ingeniero y siempre
estructura de toda la parte de las
matemáticas de los patrones de la vida y
la parte del arte fue de la parte de mi
madre que siempre estuvo viendo las
cosas de una manera caótica pero de una
manera que le daba otro sentido a todo
lo que yo veía desde chico tuve la
oportunidad desde muy pequeño de tener
muchos cambios que como yo lo vi al
principio era algo negativo tal vez era
difícil porque estuve
cambiando de ciudad varias veces en la
primaria y en la secundaria
dice toda la parte formativa en siete
diferentes escuelas
pero esto me dio la oportunidad también
de crearme cada vez que llega a un lugar
nuevo y eso ya después con el tiempo me
di cuenta que fue una gran ventaja
también que tuve porque me dio la
oportunidad de pintar cuál era mi manera
de presentarme al mundo pero siempre
teniendo una misma identidad
mi papá siempre me dijo desde chico
cuando me veía que íbamos a cambiar de
escuela otra vez porque él está en la
minería y tenemos que ir a donde
dependiendo no estaba el precio del oro
alto ahí vamos dónde estaba la plata a
la siguiente mina me decía mi hijo tú no
te preocupes el que es perico donde
quieres verde o sea que tú vas a ser el
mismo y tienes tu identidad
en tu familia así que aquí está tu tu
base tu fundamento
así fue entonces yo siempre me quedé con
esa idea dije bueno cuál cuál qué tipo
de perico soy o sea que como me voy a
identificar como cómo voy a saber cuál
es mi identidad aunque vaya a conocer un
grupo diferente de personas en cada año
y fui descubriendo mi color con el
elemento realidad del verde es que voy a
identificar que voy a definir
eso fue lo que aprendí mi padre entre
muchas otras cosas pero es lo que lo que
más me quedó grabado
pasaron los años y empecé a entrar a
cursos de música me metí en la parte de
las artes me gustó también entrar el
después en la arquitectura no me dediqué
la arquitectura pero yo pensé que ser
arquitecto
durante mucho tiempo procesada la
secundaria me metía a un despacho de
arquitectos como ayudante porque yo
quería estar dibujando los planos ahí y
aprendiendo porque yo lo quería que iba
a ser arquitecto
al mismo tiempo sabe cómo lo digo en la
música en la preparatoria entre a la
parte de las matemáticas todo esto
fueron diferentes áreas para describir
descubrir cuál va a ser mi color mi
tonalidad del verde porque yo sabía que
era un perico no entonces tenía que ver
como me iba a identificar qué es lo que
iba a ser la parte fundamental que iba a
definir quién era el maestro
y así fue fueron pasando varios este
áreas en las que él
en los que fui descubriendo
eventualmente que mi pasión era
encontrar los patrones en sistemas
complejos eso era lo que más me gustaba
en cómo me gustaba la arquitectura
porque quería estar metido con la parte
del diseño y ver cómo era la geometría
de los edificios y todo eso pero al
mismo tiempo me gustaba la música
entonces quería encontrar también el
patrón de la música pasada paso tiempo
para ver que esto era lo que realmente
la adaptación que yo tenía
y eso fue lo que me llevó a estudiar
ingeniería después que fue muy poca
distancia haber estudió física me metí a
estudia ingeniería 15x
y estuve en ingeniera cibernética
al terminar esto me fui a eeuu siempre
buscando un nuevo reto
y aquí es donde entra la parte de mi
madre que ella me dijo un consejo hace
hace unos pocos años pero realmente vale
señor desde que era niño le dijo díaz
tito que si me dicen en la vida hay que
hay que complicarse la vida para que
tenga sentido
y yo cuando lo escuché dije pues si no
siempre es complicado quizás no siempre
está metiendo en problemas y metiéndose
objetivos muy difíciles de alcanzar o
que otra gente ni siquiera se le
ocurrían
pero que le ayudaban a ella siempre
progresar y crecer
entonces yo yo eso lo tomé de una manera
tal yo no como ella me lo dijo pero lo
que había que definir siempre una manera
de estar incómodo ya tienes que estar
siempre saliendo de tu zona de confort y
buscando qué es lo siguiente que tienes
que estar haciendo lo siguiente que te
tienes que enfocar para estar
complicándose en la comunidad en la que
estás y como ingeniero o sea uno siempre
quiere buscar la optimización no quieres
estar en un estado
de paz quieres armonía no quieres tener
ningún tipo de problema
pero pero no sé cómo se platicó ya en
estas pláticas anterior a la mía es
importante siempre estar buscando
salirte de esa zona y ver cuál va a ser
el próximo reto al que te vas enfocar y
el problema que vas a solucionar
y eso es fuera ésa fue la conexión hola
las dos facetas de poder hacer algo que
te llegue a lograr tus metas es lo que
yo creo que tenemos que buscar todos
cómo podemos definir nuestra entidad
qué tonalidad de verde tienes qué tipo
de perico eres para que eso determine en
qué problemas te vas a meter para que
puedas arreglar esos problemas y llegar
al próximo paso
entonces con todo esto que empecé a
entender de la vida y cómo era dios de
chico andaba buscando cuál era mi
identidad porque es lo que termine la
carrera me casé tuve mis hijos
gonzález muy chiquito nos fuimos a vivir
a europa
sin saber sin haber ido nunca para allá
antes porque yo sabía que tenía que ir
para allá porque estaba dentro de mi
entidad yo iba a empezar un grupo de
desarrollo en dinamarca
y lo tenía que hacer y va a ser
complicarme la vida que ya tenía
establecida en san diego y ya estaba en
un buen trabajo
pero pero no era suficiente
entonces nos fuimos volamos y llegamos a
un país frío diferente con un idioma
rarísimo
pero nos fuimos adaptando
y la vida siempre es de esa manera no te
vas complicando y vas llegando un reto
nuevo y la próxima vez que te lo
enfrentas ya no es un reto grande ya lo
puedes lo puedes lograr
al cabo de un año de estar allá salió la
oportunidad de irnos a finlandia porque
nos dijeron trabaja de nokia haciendo
teléfonos nos dijeron no pues ocupamos
los voluntarios se quiere en el equipo
danés para que se vayan tres meses a
finlandia y vamos a tener un proyecto
especial
dije que no era suficiente pero yo creo
en dinamarca
y fuimos de menos 10 a menos 30 en la
temperatura que está haciendo allá pero
fueron tres meses formativos otra vez
meterme en otra bronca complicarme la
vida que ya apenas iba empezando a
formarse ya para no sabía ni por qué no
pero yo sabía que tenía que ir porque
porque era la misma tonalidad de verde
con la que yo me identificaba ya era y
seguir buscando patrones era llegar era
seguir buscando nuevos problemas a
solucionar en ingeniería en ese momento
no fuimos a finlandia regresamos a
dinamarca y
no sabía yo ni siquiera a dónde iba con
todo esto pero sabía que iba progresando
pasó el tiempo y se dio la oportunidad
de entrar al cubo
y entregó en el 2011 porque tenía un muy
buen amigo que acababa de entrar ahí me
dijo no puedes aplicar y éste ya hice
mucho tiempo y en el frío le dije pues
lo que vamos a aplicar
fui a en unas vacaciones que estaba acá
en mexicano
para una entrevista y se le entrevista
mejor no pues vamos a que conozcas el
campus y queremos entrevistar y bueno
pues un viaje gratis aa monte misión
conocida por ella de perdido que conoce
el campus que es lo que más me llamó la
atención ya fui a las entrevistas
y va sin ninguna expectativa que eso
lleva muchas veces no vas simplemente a
ver qué pasa y realmente poner tu tu
mejor esfuerzo y así llegué y me
entrevistaron y sin queden en el equipo
que me tocó fundar la la parte de de
google
pero en ese caso fue un proyecto más o
menos de un año muy emocionante porque
ser un proyecto que no podía platicarle
a nadie lo que estaba haciendo era
secreto y estamos metiendo una nueva
tecnología que no existía esto fue mucho
antes de app y todo salió primero con su
producto pero la mercadotecnia no es
nuestro fuerte llegó después del primero
total que pero no fue
efe
pero bueno la parte de pagos iba iba
creciendo y otra vez llegando la
estabilidad iba diciendo no pues aquí
esto es lo mío me tocó ir a conferencias
y todos
pero pero no era la tonalidad del verde
que a mí me interesaba no era la parte
de pagos lo que más me apasionaban que
están entendiendo a detalle cómo se
manejaban los centavos en cada
transacción de pago entonces hice un
cambio y dije no pues de esta comunidad
y el conocimiento que tengo me tengo que
salir y buscar qué sigue
se cambia el área de harvard
completamente diferente a la parte de
pagos a la parte más filantrópica de la
empresa a lanzar productos de cívicos y
de respuesta a crisis en google search
que tienen impacto a nivel mundial de
cientos de millones de personas
conectando información de datos
oficiales a las búsquedas de google
básicamente lo que hace sea cuando
tiembla en alguna ciudad o pasar a algún
evento la gente no va a la página de la
cruz roja no y si van si lo tumba en el
servidor si no tienen la estructura para
manejar ese car esa carga van a google
normalmente o van a alguna otra
plataforma digital entonces nosotros
queríamos poner esa información ahí para
los usuarios y eso sí fue este proyecto
fue un proyecto mucho más
alineado a la pasión que yo traía
que era otra vez encontrar patrones y
sistemas complejos y desmenuzar los y
entender cómo se podía utilizar esa
información de una mejor manera
entonces estos son simplemente algunos
ejemplos de lo que yo creo que todos
tenemos que hacer tenemos que buscar
siempre la
en primer lugar la identidad que tenemos
lo que de qué se trata mi vida cuál es
mi historia y yo desde chico tuve la
oportunidad de hacerlo por situaciones
de la vida no que pude probar muchas
muchas maneras de presentarme y de ver
cómo que quién era ernesto qué era lo
que iba a hacer una vez que entendí eso
aunque no lo podía articular de una
manera muy correcta pero tenían una
intuición de lo que era
pues era complicarme la vida cada paso
que llegaba lo podía conquistar como un
videojuego que lo llegas y pasas este
nivel pero ahora tienes que pasar que sí
y la única manera de pasar al que sigue
es meterte no puedes quedarte soñando y
de si no pues me gustaría llegar para
allá algún día y voy a hacer un plan a
veces simplemente hay que hacerlo como
lo hace mi madre
te metes y ya que estás ahí y ahí ves
cómo o cómo salir
no es algo muy elegante ni nada pero
pero realmente así es como como como yo
lo he hecho y llevo ocho años en google
porque en cierta forma la empresa se
maneja de esa manera también es un caso
ordenado uno piensa que google está muy
bien organizado desde arriba y que una
persona que planea todo pero no es
cierto pues tratan de contratar gente
muy muy capaz para que ellos sean los
que tengan la innovación desde abajo y
se habilita el desarrollo individual
para que cada persona pueda innovar
me gustó mucho un par de frases que dice
nuestro fundador muy seguido habla el de
detener
como dice en inglés es saben
una
es una que me encanta que siempre dice
larry page o sea no tenerle miedo son
una manera saludable de no tenerle miedo
a lo imposible
porque todo lo que es imposible es donde
están las mayores oportunidades porque
ahí no va a haber competencia toda la
gente se enfoca en lo que es posible en
lo que se puede lograr pero lo imposible
nada más unos pocos lo van a hacer
entonces él dice no pues por ahí te vas
y nadie te va a competir vas a poder
llegar fácil va a ser el primero hay
pérdidas y es que llegamos
e
y la otra que me gusta también es
cuando habla de siempre estar trabajando
en algo que sea incómodamente excitante
o emocionante para tu vida
que viene siendo esto otra vez hacerte
la vida difícil para poder lograr los
objetivos en google todo lo que estamos
haciendo siempre es incómodamente
excitante o sea no no vamos a estar
nunca trabajando lo mismo en lo que se
hizo el año anterior y hacerlo
gradualmente mejor no es buscar siempre
el 10 veces más no vamos a alcanzar si
este año pudimos lanzar un producto en
10 países en 100 y así ese es el nivel
de escala que estamos buscando siempre
siempre en el área de de conectar al
mundo no de la información actualmente
estoy trabajando en él en el área de
search
involucra muchas áreas en la parte
conectando datos todavía de diferentes
fuentes en compañías de todo el mundo
hacia la el gráfico
graf la la base de datos de google y
para esto
hay que pensar creativo hay que estarse
metiendo en problemas está el tiempo no
tienes el objetivo que quieres lograr y
[Música]
es buscar las maneras de llegar a eso
como sea
de acuerdo a la circunstancia de cada
país y de cada partner con el que
trabajemos
pero nuevamente no siempre buscando con
una misma identidad romper tu zona de
confort para llegar al objetivo que
quieres yo creo que el nombre que le
puse a esta charla fuera fue vive tu
camino porque para mí esa es la manera
de realmente experimentar y estar vivo
en el camino el que te toca en la vida
en el poco tiempo que tenemos como se
comenta no porque es muy corto y es
desconocido que tan corto va a ser
pero solamente de esa manera vas a poder
guiarlo y hacer lo tuyo y realmente
estar orgulloso de lo que logres gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]